hey did Beth ever tell you why she went
out with you after you sh yourself on
the
date so for those of you who don't know
I my first date with that we went out my
first date with Beth I yourself you
yourself I don't think I have to
say accidentally myself I think
that's probably implied I mean yeah he
didn't do it on purpose as a grown man I
don't think I'm at dinner like wait a
second
she told me why and I and this is one of
the things that I love about her she was
like listen I never want you to
yourself
again but I'm not going to lie that was
quite a roller coaster of
emotions she loves like I'm a little all
over the place so I think she kind of
picked up on that and was like this dude
is going to himself I wonder what
else he's got up his sleep you know what
I mean